how many times a day do you think you gawk at the opposite sex?
Mark Ireland a researcher from Kodak lens vision centre
carried out a study that interviewed three thousand British individuals
questioning females and males on how often the gawk at the gender they're attracted to
result show men between the ages of eighteen and fifty
spend an average of 43 minutes a day eyeing members of the opposite sex
summing up to almost one year in an average lifetime
women on the other hand spend an average of six months of their lifetime eyeing males
most female participants in the study shared
it was a fellow's dazzling eyes that first drew their gaze
with men it was the lady's figure
for men the top five spots for them to eye at women are
supermarkets
pubs slash bars
nightclubs
work and shops
for women the top five spots are
pubs slash bars
shops
public transportation
supermarkets
and work
although the majority of the participants stated that beign eyed makes them feel flattered
twenty eight percent said it made them feel happy
sixteen percent said it made them feel uncomfortable
and twenty percent said it embarrasses them
another interesting find
was how partners reacted to each others wandering eyes
one third of the poll members have argued with their partner over wandering eyes
with one in ten breaking up with their partner because of it
but on a more positive note
thirty five percent of brits shared they started a relationship with someone they eyed-up
and question of the day
would you be empathetic if you caught your partner staring at another attractive person?
or would you be like the other one thousand Brits who argued with their partners
leave that in the comments bellow